c'est un retour dans le passé pour le
château des mesnuls qui propose une
reconstitution lors du règne de louis 15
costumes décoration ateliers jeux de
rôles étaient prévues toute la journée
pour accueillir les visiteurs
animations axées cette année
principalement sur les costumes les
costumes multi-époques donc du 15e
siècle jusqu'au xviiie un peu de lempire
aussi le château des mesnuls est réservé
à l'année par des entreprises comme le
domaine de saint paul qui depuis 2012
est un centre pour séminaires en 1959 le
domaine était alors un centre de
recherche pour des ingénieurs et de
l'expertisé du bâtiment on a mis en
visite pas les deux les trois bâtiments
emblématiques qui sont donc ce hold et
c'est qu'ils étaient sains au décès ce
bâtiment à 3 kit qui a été entièrement
transformée en salle de séminaire on a
aussi un autre bâtiment qui était pas un
vol d'essai et bien sûr l'hôtel
restaurant
direction le village du tremblay sur
mauldre qui a privilégié pour ce
week-end une déambulation sur les pas du
poète blaise cendrars une façon de
visiter le village mais aussi de
parfaire ses connaissances littéraires
dans les parties du cimetière où ses
cendres ont été transférés en 1994
on est remonté jusque là mairie pour
lire son article consacré au village
pendant la guerre 939
et pour terminer devant sa maison qui
est un lieu privé nous avons lu quelques
textes qui évoquent la maison
l'intérieur et l'extérieur
un week end riche en histoire
littérature et culture lors de ces
journées du patrimoine dans le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse des lieux fermés qui ont pu
être découverts ou redécouverts par le
public